pour en parler on va rejoindre tout de
suite manon le breton membre des
constituants est élu rural
bonsoir bonsoir manon lebreton merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france un
commentaire d'abord peut-être sur cette
probable poussée des verts pour ce
premier tour écoutez non franchement je
n'ai pas très envie de commenter ces
courses de petits chevaux il me semble
assez sidérant d'assister à ce type de
commentaire là ce soir
à l'heure où on est dans une urgence
maximale et on devrait l'être en tout
cas et on a l'impression que ce petit
monde politique a vite fait d'oublier la
gravité de la situation
moi ce qui me frappe c'est c'est la
confusion totale qui ressort de ce
scrutin
la difficulté pour les électeurs pour
les pour nos concitoyens à se situer
dans dans cette confusion un savoir quoi
faire
confronté à des injonctions
contradictoires il fallait aller voter
tout en restant chez soi pour ne pas
prendre de risque enfin vraiment il
était absolument impossible de savoir où
était enfin il me semble pour le citoyen
lambda extrêmement difficile de savoir
où se situer son devoir des citoyens
malgré tout l'abstention record massive
et historique qui s'est donné à voir
montre que la plupart de nos concitoyens
avaient conscience de cette priorité
absolue de la du danger que consignes
que constitue à l'heure actuelle
l'évolution de l'épidémie
voilà donc mon jeu je crois que vraiment
de notre devoir de en tant que co
observateurs politiques moi en tant que
telus rural vous l'avez rappelé c'est ça
aurait été d'abord et ça a été mon cas
d'appeler à ne pas se rendre à ces
élections
elle n'aurait pas dû se tenir je pense
que le gouvernement ait un certain
nombre de représentants politiques ont
manqué totalement sont passés à côté
d'eux de leurs devoirs républicains en
l'occurrence qui aurait été
de d'annuler de repousser en tout cas ce
scrutin des temps plus calme aurelio
vous attendez quoi ce soir comme
attitude comme parole des candidats à
ces municipales maintenant le breton
maintenant le breton pardon écoutez moi
il me semble que globalement enfin on
est dans une situation qui est la
suivante c'est à dire que au départ
emmanuel macron et la majorité ont
essayé de d'instrumentaliser cette
situation sanitaire qui s'annonçait
d'emblée assez grave
je pense par exemple enfin souvenons
nous que il y à peine quinze jours
edouard philippe profitez d'un conseil
des ministres consacré soit disant oh
coronavirus pour annoncer le 49-3 sur
les retraites
donc on voit bien qu'en réalité la
majorité et une grande partie du monde
politique je le regrette mais je
constate c'est de ceux de cette
situation sanitaire
le cadet de ses soucis aujourd'hui et ça
et pendant longtemps un prétexte je
crois que la majorité mais emmanuel
macron se sont retrouvés piégés dans
cette attitude dans leur propre
communication optimiste hyper optimiste
en disant un coup aller au théâtre aller
en terrasse continue à vivre comme avant
soyez libres etc
c'est un discours absolument
irresponsable et aujourd'hui ce que je
constate ce soir c'est que finalement
une grande partie du des candidats des
des responsables politiques ont l'air
d'avoir totalement oublier le caractère
exceptionnel de cette abstention qui
fausse la sincérité du scrutin et qui
devrait ne laisser aucune hésitation sur
le sort à donner à ces élections à ce
scrutin pour la suite c'est à dire que
il est évident que on devrait aller dans
les jours qui viennent vers une
annulation du scrutin puisque le
deuxième tour ne pourra pas se tenir en
tout cas j'espère que les les mesures
sanitaires seront tels que on renoncera
comme le réclament les médecins comme
l'ont réclamé les soignants toute la
journée aujourd'hui que les scrutins ne
puisse pas se tenir car c'est faire
courir un risque sanitaire
d'autant plus grand à la population le
gouvernement qui veut réunir demain à
partir de demain des experts et les
responsables des politiques pour prendre
position à savoir s'il y aura un second
tour ou pas vous pensez que c'est
maintenant qu'il faut décider
il faut l'annuler tout de suite ce
second tour sachant qu'aujourd'hui le
nouveau bilan est de 127 morts et 5423
cas confirmés en france on
s'acheminerait dit certains vers un
scénario italien donc on sent un certain
flottement en tout cas dans la rapidité
vous le disiez de prendre des décisions
et bien sûr la seule attitude
responsable de la part de des politiques
et de nos gouvernants en l'occurrence
puisqu'il avait la main pour le faire
qu'ils sont si prompts à prendre des
décisions verticale est immédiate
j'ai bien c'était l'occasion là de
montrer qu'il était capable de le faire
pour suspendre ce scrutin comme je
disais dès la veille de ceux de ce
premier tour aujourd'hui je pense à tous
ceux qui nous regardent je pense à ces
responsables médicaux qui vont êtres qui
sont déjà mobilisés dans les hôpitaux je
pense aux italiens et aux espagnols qui
sont confrontés à la situation qui nous
attend probablement d'ici une semaine
maximum
à savoir cette saturation absolue des
hôpitaux on en voit déjà les prémices en
france et on a affaire à des gens qui se
comportent comme si on pouvait se
demander dans cette ce que j'ai appelé
cette course 7 course de petits chevaux
se demander qui arrive un peu en tête ce
comme si on était dans une situation
normale il est évident qu'aujourd'hui le
la seul site la seule attitude
responsable
c'est de renoncer à ces élections et
donc ça impliquera de d'annuler les
résultats de ce premier tour c'est
terrible de se dire qu'on a déployé tous
tous ses moyens toute cette énergie et
qu'on a exposé autant de concitoyens
alors que vraisemblablement il ne
restera rien ou très peu de ceux de ce
premier tour et pour finir je crois que
enfin je garde en tête ces mots
extrêmement forts d'un médecin qui s'est
rendu dans un bureau de vote pour
constater la façon dont ce se dérouler
le scrutin
c'est un médecin stéphanois je crois
qu'ils disaient vous compter les votes
et nous nous quatre nous compterons les
morts hier je crois que c'est vraiment
la phrase devrait qui devrait résonner
dans l'esprit de ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui responsables de cette
situation en ayant maintenu ce scrutin
j'espère qu effectivement le second tour
ne tardera pas à être annulée puisque de
toute façon il est évident que la
situation sanitaire ne permettra pas
dans un contexte de confinement
s'annonce bientôt absolue ne permettra
pas de mener au bout ce deuxième
immersive au cours manon lebreton merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur r&d
france on va écouter anne hidalgo la
maire sortant de paris nice saison